As we just saw, we're limited in what we can
represent in tabular data. In many situations, we have data items
with fields that have sub-fields. As programmers we are accustomed
to this way of thinking, we have objects that have fields,
that reference other objects. And, a lot of times all
the objects have several fields of their own. So here we're
looking at the The Beatles discography page on Wikipedia. This
is the page we use to produce that data that we
looked at earlier. Okay, so if we were to
represent this data in the tabular form, in a
CSV file or Excel worksheet, we'd need to do
some unwinding. Given that we've got certifying authorities here, and
different types of certifications. Gold record, Platinum record, and
so on. There's also this additional complicating factor that
an individual record can be certified as some multiple.
Platinum. So this particular album is a multi platinum record,
four times platinum. Platinum means it sold a million
copies. Four times platinum means it sold more than
four million copies. So if we want to represent
this part of this dataset in a tabular form, we
would essentially need two columns for every certifying authorities.
One for what level of certification, and one for the
multiplier. Aside from being tedious and error prone, this
is just a really unnatural way to represent this data.
So, this is why the JSON standard has emerged for
modeling data and as a means of transmitting data between
systems. So, let's take a look at a way of
representing this data in JSON. I'm just going to look
at A Hard Day's Night. A Hard Day's Night is
interesting because it was actually released on two different labels
on two different dates. So let's take a look then
at how we might do this in JSON. All right.
So what I've done is I've taken just the Hard
Day's Night data and implemented it as a JSON object.
Okay, so you can see we have a field for
title, artist and releases. And as we scroll down through
this data, you can see that releases is actually an
array. Okay? In this case I've got two because if
you remember we have two different releases for this. One
on the United Artists label and one of the Parlophone
label. Okay? What we've done here as well Because
the chart positions are in reference to a specific
release, we need to make them part of the
appropriate release object within the releases array. So in this
case, the peak chart position for the United Artists
release of A Hard Day's Night in France was
five, in the UK was one. We also need
to associate the certifications with the release, because a different
release will have different certifications. So here we've got
the different certifying authorities and then for that RIAA
certification, it has a multiplier of four because it
was actually a four times platinum album. Okay. And
here is the release data for the other release,
the one on Parlophone. So this is a way
of representing the data in JSON. And it's important
to note that JSON objects are just like dictionaries
in Python and many other languages. There's a data
type in most programming languages that's analogous to a JSON
object. In Python it happens to be a dictionary.
Many other languages have dictionary or map like data types
that are very similar to JSON object. And most
programming languages have arrays as well. In Python, they happen
to be called lists. Okay, so let's just document
some of what we have to remember about JSON here.